لذلك نشأت في
عائلة محافظة حيث
لا يجب على النساء التسلق والسفر بمفردهن ،
لذا فقد ساعدني المجيء إلى دبي حقًا
في العثور على جميع الرياضات التي
استمتعت بها بالطريقة التي يجب أن تعيد بها الاتصال
بالطبيعة إلى الأرض الأم لتشعر بها  أفضل
عن نفسك ، اسمي مارك
بومونت وأنا رياضي قدرة تحمل
الرقم القياسي العالمي الحالي لركوب الدراجات
حول الكوكب
بحثًا عن المغامرات وإيجاد القصص
هو السبب الذي يجعلني أكثر شغفًا به
منذ أن أتذكر أنني شعرت بهذا
الإحساس  فضولها حول العالم هذه
المرة عدت لأقوم به
هنا أنا أتناول فيتا لأسمع كيف ساعدها
حبها للهواء الطلق ورياضات المغامرة
بشكل كبير على توخي الحذر
جسديًا وذهنيًا
[موسيقى
] لا أحاول غالبًا شيئًا ما
لم يسبق له مثيل من قبل أن التزلج على الألواح للأطفال
لا يتوسل إلى اسكتلندا في مايو
لأنه بارد جدًا ،
لذا ضع علامة على الوقت الذي يبدأ فيه القارب في التحرك ،
وتشعر به وأنت تعيش معه
، ثم تنظر إلى القارب
وتستمتع به دائمًا  كانت نشطة في دبي
ولكن بعد ذلك تعرضت
لكسر في الفخذ ولم أستطع فعل
أي شيء لمدة عام وكانت هذه
نقطة التحول بالنسبة لي وهذا ما
جعلني أصبح أكثر ميلًا إلى المغامرة.
جرب كل ما
لم أستطع فعله في ذلك العام
وهنا بدأت رحلتي
[موسيقى]
أعتقد حقًا أن التمتع بصحة
بدنية أمر مهم للغاية ، لكني
أركز حقًا على أن أكون بصحة جيدة عقليًا
أكثر في أي وقت أشعر فيه بالإحباط أو
أشعر بقلق شديد.  حزمت حقائبي وسافر
إلى الجبال أو اذهب للتخييم أو
فقط في الهواء الطلق وأعد الاتصال
بنفسي لأن شخصًا يعاني من
القلق من الخروج في الهواء الطلق والنشاط
ساعدني كثيرًا وما زال
يعني أنك تشعر وكأنك مليون
أميال من دبي هنا أعرف ناطحات سحاب
الجبال ناطحات سحاب طبيعية
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] تصبح مظلمة بسرعة كبيرة جدًا ويبدو هذا
صغيرًا من قاع الوادي انظر
إليه على قمة العالم
رياضات المغامرة الجميلة الرائعة واكتشف  ng كما
تعلمون في النهاية من وقتنا
معًا ، هذا نوع من إنشاء
هويتك ، إنه نوع من هويتك ، وأنا أعلم
أن هدفي هو الحصول على المزيد والمزيد من
الأشخاص في الهواء الطلق مثل هذا
شيء أريد أن أفعله لأكون نشطًا وأكون
أقرب  ستجعلك الطبيعة
شخصًا أفضل عقليًا
وجسديًا ، لقد أحببت
هذا تمامًا وأنت تعرف أروع جزء
تعرف أنك كنت صادقًا جدًا بشأن
رحلتك ، فأنت تعرف ما الذي
تم القيام به من أجلك في كل هذه المغامرات ،
شكرًا لك و  آمل أن نبتسم ،
إنه لمن دواعي سروري
أنت